hey let's going bros my name is Pippa
and welcome to five weird stuff that I
found online the greatest show on the
planet we have so many amazing items
today bro so let's get right to it
but first I need to change it to my new
outfit oh my god pugs everywhere okay
well how do I look you can't you can't
see my titties but here let me show you
we've had some nice titties on this show
but these bad boys oh yeah
the second item of this week is another
outfit but this time it's not for me
what the hell does that mean that
Garrett you're gonna look fabulous oh
god damn it not again oh yeah this is
definitely too tiny Maya come here man
it looks like it's Maya's turn to shine
today yeah my little princess just gonna
look it doesn't matter if you don't like
it oh my god you're fat
Jesus Christ this dress is about to pop
it fits me perfect look at the back it's
about to explode what shut up
can I get a kiss now my ass no please
come on
what's that sponsor eagle sponsor eagle
whoa oh my god thank you sponsor eagle
sponsor eagle has blessed us with
another lootcrate package yeah okay I
see a lot of good stuff right here
already
for those who don't know a loot crate is
a monthly paid service if you enter the
code views into the website loot crate
comms I spirits again 10% up and if you
see anything you like then you can do
that every month there's a new theme
this theme is unite so let's check it
out we got this is t-shirt let me look
at it that's pretty [ __ ] cool that's
powering this right yeah it is
oh yeah now I can finally cover up my
titties goddammit okay I see you awesome
bucks
what is this Rick and Morty I love that
show
[ __ ] yeah what is it it's a puzzle box
oh cool Marvel ice cube tray so you can
make little ice cubes up Avengers ooh
Team Fortress bobby pins I think they're
called my favorite is a unicorn one
Marvel shoelaces just what I needed what
the hell loot crate special edition of
Mad I thought they stopped printing mad
Avengers sticker
I don't think you can see it ooh bravest
warriors
[ __ ] yeah that's awesome all right I
rise from the crater of Adventure Time
their new show I haven't watched it I've
seen some teasers of it but it comes
with a comic book and that's [ __ ]
awesome
I'll definitely read that and that's
only for fur loot crate the box is
always like a game as well which is
really cool but yeah it's really fun and
exciting to to get a package every month
so if this seems interesting to you like
I said check out loot crate calm slash
boots them to a book code pewds you get
10% off next month theme is going to be
I don't know sponsor eagle tell me next
month SEMA cipher you still hate you
cyber next month is cyber Terminator
Borderlands Battlestar Galactica
that's the theme if you have your loot
crate tweet at me hashtag loot pills so
I can see them
alright let's move on to the next item
a lot of a lot of outfits in this
episode oh it's a selfie shirt for those
who don't know it's the ship name of
zoella Alfie and you can buy it and wear
it if you ship them you obviously need
to wear the shirt there you go
fits great on my my titties
and uh yeah this is nice
[ __ ] happened to his channel I am Number
Four is candy but it's not just any
candy it's poop candy so there it's
called pooping pet candy dispenser it's
basically this penguin who poops out
chocolate and then that you can eat
I hope it's chocolate no it's not it's
jellybeans let's try it out okay so you
can charge it from the top let me put
them in I will take this one straight
from the pooper
I bet you think oh boy this items sure
we're amazing this week what is he gonna
do to top these well before the final
item we have I'm sure you've seen
already it's toilet gold so you can make
one go in the hole while you make it go
out of the hole let's try it out
it even comes with this so you can poop
I mean punch I mean without being
disturbed all right here we go
come on man all right
wasn't that amazing I think probably the
best don't forget to check out a loot
crate outcome size parents if you're
interested I'll see you in the next one
as always stay awesome bros hi how's it
going Brooke hi Hong Kong bras pulling
fire here welcome to fight
what are you doing it Rufus yeah